this is just McDonnell standing in for
reviewer Ginny woo
monster hunter world ice-born is more of
the same glorious slog for everyone
who's ever been taken down by a
fire-breathing pack simile of a
Tyrannosaurus Rex and thought I can't
wait to do that 50 times over the
franchise has always rewarded those
willing to put in the hard yards and
ice-born is no exception it adds more of
what set the base game aside from its
predecessors without feeling overcrowded
even if its narrative could have used a
little more work just like the Fitz
Banner Lux on our side since monster
hunter world's launch the game has seen
a steady drip feed of DLC content in the
form of in-game events many of these
follow the formula of transplanting
something fearsome into an already
familiar environment the design
philosophy behind monster hunter world
ice-born takes a similar approach in
implementing that sort of content though
on a larger scale it uses touchstones in
the form of storied foes and familiar
locations to build upon the robust
ecosystem of the base game which
delivers an experience that will test
your mettle without breaking you shortly
after the successes of dealing with the
base games elder dragon predicament a
mass migration event shakes the
recovering ecosystem of astera and
prompts you to investigate what comes
next is a tale of family legacies
mysterious scales and your handler
embarking on her own personal quest to
ship the focus of the story from the
protagonist to what is essentially a
side character is a bold one for all the
aid and assistance that the handler
gives in monster hunter world she's
still fundamentally a living breathing
quest board players will no doubt have
become attached to her over the course
of their travels but is that attachment
deep enough to shoulder a full
expansions narrative conceit not quite
as soon as you're introduced to the
latest curveball about ice borns new
signature location hoarfrost reach and
how that intersects rather conveniently
with your handlers past you're
immediately whisked back to the lands
and territories from the base game to
cull a couple of monsters that have
gotten too big for their boots it's not
exactly narrative whiplash but
certainly not as compelling as it would
have been have we been the ones to
follow the handler from the first step
of her journey to the new lands of
ice-born that said revisiting those
familiar locations early on to take down
new and improved versions of killer
dinosaurs that you've faced before it's
one of the most compelling parts of the
game as with the DLC strategy the
building blocks of the expansion of
steeped in elements that existing
players are already acquainted with the
changes that ice-born makes in the form
of these variant breeds has a two-fold
effect first they provide you with the
motivation to form new strategies to
slice and dice their way to the next
story beat secondly just distinct enough
in terms of attack patterns and
additional elemental considerations that
you never really feel like you're just
fighting a reskin of something you made
mincemeat out of 80 hours ago it's as if
there's been a concerted effort to
balance the difficulty of what many fans
might rightfully view as the second
coming of the coveted G rank in this
latest iteration
despite some focus on iterating
established systems that are innovations
introduced in ice-born that truly set it
apart from its predecessor brand new
monsters and the implementation of
legacy series favorites look and feel
impressive thanks to all the new ways
monsters can interact with other beasts
and the various location
but more importantly there is a
library's worth of new weapon moves for
you to take advantage of charge acts
users can now cancel into a particularly
fun multi-directional attack when caught
unawares and gun Lance users no longer
have to worry about running out of ammo
in an emergency before getting to use
their new signature move that is quite
literally explosive hunting-horn users
will also have had their ability to do
damage buffed with the addition of a new
move that lets you stick your horn in
the ground and spin it like some kind of
bizarre beyblade to catch whatever is
charging towards you off-guard that's
just a few new examples but overall
these additions seem to be informed by
the dual precepts of style and lethality
however the biggest quality-of-life
addition has been something called the
clutch claw every hunter can use this
alongside their primary weapon to
grapple onto their foe and depending on
what other sharp object is equipped do
anything from steering a rampaging wave
and into a rock face to weakening a
specific part of its body that needs to
be lopped off having the option and
ability to scale up the side of a
monster after landing a savvy shot with
the clutch cloth feels ridiculously
satisfying and the surge is driving a
beast to its doom in the many
treacherous terrain pitfalls that dot
hoarfrost reach that new frosty
landscape is beautiful and treacherous
in equal measure
with new foes more verticality than the
Kuril Highlands and frozen terrain that
can crack and send you plunging to your
death it really is a sight to behold
more than ever it feels like the
environment can be turned against you
some monsters will uproot trees and
throw them at you while the wrong move
on cracked ice can mean certain death
having a grasp of every bit of the map
is integral to truly mastering what ice
one has to throw at you and it's
incredibly satisfying when everything
suddenly clicks and you go from the
hunted to the hunter leading their prey
to a painful trap that attempts to even
the scales being dropped into this
intricately designed location as a
relatively new player may be
overwhelming but no matter your
experience level joining up with other
hunters and picking your way through the
icy den of beasts together is incredibly
rewarding in its own way
and iceborn benefits from the
matchmaking improvements introduced
since the release of the base game
Monster Hunter World ice-born is at its
best when you're fighting tooth and nail
against something that you know could
crush you within its teeth in a second
even though this might feel like it came
at the expense of a more interesting
narrative nothing is quite as good as
the biting chill cutting through the
first of your armor the shrill cry of
your palico as it comes to your aid and
the wind roaring in your ears as you
latch on to a beasts flank and climb up
its side while it [ __ ] and roars this
expansion is rife with moments like that
all of the improvements feel like they
were done with the excellent building
blocks of Monster Hunter world in mind
which means that getting to the meat of
the matter is quicker and more
satisfying than ever there's no more
fussing about with the new systems or
worrying about ruffling the feathers of
hardcore fans with the direction change
in the series those teething problems
have already come and gone
I spawn is a confident step into the
future of the franchise and it's hard
not to think about what might come next
thanks for being here you're a lifesaver